the jurogan experience you have
something
yeah so this is a breaking story and uh
former deputy assistant secretary of
defense for intelligence christopher
mellon
uh literally sent this to me about 15
minutes ago and he wanted me to read it
a verbatim so i was going to read this
is pretty startling stuff so i'll read
it
in the last 48 hours the public has
learned of two stunning incidents
captured on film
by u.s navy carrier pilots earlier this
year
one of the cases features a photo of a
bizarre flying sphere
and a black cube inside that is
identical to dozens of other reports
by navy pilots these strange objects
have been shadowing east coast naval ops
since
2015. they sometimes maneuver in
formation and have occasionally
been reported achieving supersonic
speeds
the other incident produced a stunning
detailed photograph of a massive
triangular shaped vehicle
that emerged from the ocean and flew
vertically
straight up and out of sight just past a
navy f-18
operating off the u.s aircraft carrier
these iphone photos taken by the pilots
should be released to the public
as there are no sources and methods to
protect
and the national security benefits of
raising awareness
regarding this issue vastly outweigh
any conceivable benefit from concealing
the information
it is hard to believe that in the face
of such radical
and incredible technology within our
vast defense department
the only we only have a so-called task
force consisting of two individuals with
no budget
who are still being off are stiff-armed
for access to relevant and timely
information by the air force
and other security organizations
by comparison 60 years ago in response
to sputnik
america entered the space race which led
to landing on the moon
our government needs to wake up and
address the far
greater technology gap that these and
many other incidents are revealing
there is obviously a glaring strategic
mismatch between the current
task force and the technology that has
been identified
why did he send you this because he felt
the developing story and he wants
people to be aware that there's really
compelling evidence right now
photographically that needs to be
released
and so you told him you were coming on
here and that's when he sent it to you
yes and he said that these people need
to feel some pressure um
they need to they need to know that we
are requesting not demanding but
requesting
further government transparency on this
issue and he's very passionate about it
he knows of these photographs
the governments we got the story i think
it was yesterday
and the government is refusing to
release these photographs the pilots
want these photographs released the
people
involved with the incident want the
photographs released and so
we he wants the public to know that
these photographs exist
and that they should be released and
they're currently in the possession of
uh he wouldn't reveal that he knows the
person but but he said that the
government is not wanting them released
and he feels that they
that we have a right to these
photographs and there's video that came
with this story as well
well remember this comes from the very
guy who
was strategic christopher mellon in
getting those
videotaped evidence from the cockpits of
those f-18 fighter jets
off the east coast as well as off the
west coast in 2004 2015
and ended up with that big story on the
front page of the new york times in
2017.
yeah see that that's a new
thing because if you went to like
24 or 2004 when this all happened
no one was really talking about ufos in
a serious manner like
it was still something that would be
mocked and ridiculed but to have it on
the front page of the new york times
and to have this spokesperson for the
pentagon say
that they've recovered off-world
vehicles
not from this earth not made on this
earth like this is a
this is a change right a really i mean
even though
it doesn't receive that much public
attention because it's all happening
during a pandemic
and everyone's just and also the news
cycle today is so bizarre
something gets into the news cycle and
then it's gone tomorrow because some new
scandal or
people find out ellen's mean or whatever
it is there's always something new
that's coming out
and these these things though they seem
to it seems to be there's more of them
and more of them coming out and with
each new story that comes out people
feel more emboldened
to tell their story you know
i think personally everything changed in
december of 20 2017 when that
page a front page the new york times
revealed that secret a tip program
and um i know personally because i've
gotten ridiculed for decades for the
work i do
a lot less so recently people are
suddenly raising an eyebrow going
wow there's clearly something more to
this and just you know radar
weather balloons and and misidentified
aircraft jimmy pull up the video
of that's in that article there's a
there's an actual youtube video there's
two
ones from 94 ones from 2013. let's go
with the 2013 one
um but these uh videos are
very strange you see these this object
what's interesting too
is that okay this is the one that i
didn't see but that this thing
the way it moves and behave the one
that's from i guess it was from the 94
one this is the 2013 one
this is the one from puerto rico so it's
just kind of cruising across
the sky it's hard to track here in this
black and white
there it is
does it estimate how fast this thing is
supposedly going
it looks like they were near uh some
sort of like military base or something
and on aguadilla which is like the west
coast
so weird to see like it's not clear what
this thing is
so one of the things that i think it's
really good to establish go
go i'm sorry but go go further ahead in
this video to see if maybe there's a
better version of it or a better
check the other one has a little clear
video
yeah there you go that's much clearer
like what is that
well that's not a bird like
yes moving through the clouds one of the
things i wanted to make a distinction of
is the technology the observed
technology that these guys are talking
about
so you've got objects with
no wings no visible means of propulsion
the ability to hover accelerate from a
standstill to out of sight in the blink
of an eye
right angle turns at high speed fly
rings around our fastest jets
that is the technology that cannot be
confused or explained away as something
conventional
so anytime you see an object like we're
looking at here if it performs or
exhibits
that technology maybe it shoots off at a
high rate of speed does the right angle
turn at high speeds
no wings no tail no propulsion
no sonic boom almost no sound
that's and they're trying to get a
close-up on this thing
so you get a better idea of what the
shape is it's very hard to tell
but these objects also one of the weird
things is it moves around the same way
commander fraver described that thing
moving around
that was hovering over the ocean that it
kind of darts around
left and right right and left almost
like it's just
not connected to
what whatever our atmosphere is it's
like it's moving into this weird
zigzag sort of a way
this is an infrared image right it's not
a
visible it's not a normal camera
i don't know i don't know what looks
like today it is
same type of camera that uh
as the one from the nimitz so you're
looking at the heat signature
you're not really looking at the visual
picture right so that's
that's why it's not not you cannot get a
clear
definition of it well they need better
cameras
so did you go further along in the video
it does uh
they do get a better view of it there it
is there you go
like what the hell is that
you know that was one of the uh more
startling
uh moments of producing the film the
phenomenon for me was when i met with
senator harry reid who spearheaded the
atip program the advanced aerospace
threat
identification program that wound up on
the front page of the new york times
i wasn't quite sure when i met with him
how where his comfort zone was and so i
was really kind of cautious for the
first half an hour of the interview
but then i started we started to relax
and and get more comfortable with each
other
and i decided to kind of push it a
little bit and i said hey
senator i met with gordon cooper
who later became mercury astronaut who
told me on camera that there was a
landing incident that took place
at edwards air force base circa 1957
where they happen to have a camera crew
out
near the dry lake bed capturing the
installation of a new landing facility
for f-86 fighter jets
and it was broad daylight and all of a
sudden this disc appears out of nowhere
and the camera crew turned their cameras
on it and they filmed
the landing of this flying saucer on the
dry lake bed at edwards air force base
and i'm telling the story
to senator reed thinking you know i
don't know how he's going to react when
i
but this is what i was i have him on
camera
and uh and he said he has the film
footage developed it was good footage he
held it up he looked at it it was a disc
you know blah blah
and uh eventually he gets a courier jet
from washington dc that flies in
pick up the footage senator reid goes
and it was never seen or heard from
again and i said yeah
exactly and i said did you guys uncover
stuff like that
he goes oh yeah it's all there it's we
we have it it's all there and then he
goes to change the topic
and talk about something else and i said
well hold on senator
uh are you saying that there's evidence
that hasn't seen the light of day
and he looked at me and he kind of
pauses and he picks up his water bottle
he drinks a sip of water and that
that that moment seemed like an hour but
it was probably just a second or two
and he puts his water bottle down he
says i'm saying that most of the
evidence hasn't seen the light of day
so that that for me
was such a powerful moment because i'm
going look at who this is coming from
this is the former
head of you know senate majority leader
harry reid saying that the vast majority
of
evidence hasn't seen the light of day
and if the president of the united
states can't get access to it
as i found out when i interviewed all
the people around president
clinton who can who has the authority
to have this stuff released and that's
something that i would love to know
and i've been trying to find out so
someone does someone in some position of
government
or some intelligence agency someone in
the pentagon
someone or some group at the highest
level of clearance
has access to this information and knows
about it
absolutely senator reid said they
uncovered all this stuff
during the program and he said the level
of resistance that he got from the
intelligence agencies
was insane like i mean they did not want
this project going forward at the
pentagon
but they pushed and they pushed and they
pushed and they got it through started
in 2007 it went all the way up until it
ended up on the front page
of the new york times in 2017. and of
course now we know that there's another
project but
jacques do you know who has the
authority to release this stuff
to the general public
no no not not in in this particular case
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience